[Music]
we're gathered here this morning for a
very happy
occasion occasion in which the academy
recognizes the work of young people the
people who will someday be taking our
places tonight we're here to see the
best student films in the country and
honor the filmmakers we flown the
winning students in from across the
country they spent the last few days
meeting professional filmmakers and
seeing the way we make movies in
Hollywood but after seeing their movies
boy do we have something to
learn this is a very moving occasion for
members of The
Academy all 4,000 of us people in every
facet of film making once stood where
the young filmmakers we're celebrating
tonight are standing on the threshold of
their careers asking themselves am I on
the right track well these awards are
meant to say yes you're terrific you're
talented you're on your way stick with
it and go the
distance if you can be recognized by
this Academy it really says something
for
you it tells the people in the industry
that you can tell a story on film to
have an award like this
validates all the hours and hours he
spent locked in that room I would really
like to address my colleagues new
filmmakers and future filmmakers I hope
that we will use our abilities to give
people choices to bring joy but also to
challenge people's perceptions and maybe
we can contribute in some small way to
bettering this
world I think what we're looking at
tonight is uh the harbinger of the next
years and I think that's very optimistic
I'm very pleased about
that